Les amis, bienvenue à Busana
Les amis, nous sommes au "Gamcheon Culture village "
C'est un endroit très atypique qui a l'air très très cool
Je vais vous en dire plus dans un instant parce que là je vais bouffer
J'ai la dalle
Tous ça là je mange, je mange
Même lui je le mange !
Ok les amis
J'ai trouvé ma bouffe
J'ai trouvé des chats
Ambiance tamisée-posée, toi même tu sais
La particularité de ce village c'est qu'il y a plein de ... de street art
Des petits tags...
Des petites œuvres...
Comme ceci
Voilà
Le Petit Prince revisité, avec un petit Vespa toi même tu connais
Pour séduire de la meuf à 14 ans
Les petites sandales tranquilou
Hein, ça c'est une faute de goût
Du coup on est dans les hauteurs là, tout ça ça été fabriqué sur une putain de colline
Fabriqué... On dirait qu'on parle d'un jouet : ça été construit sur une colline
Et regardez du coup on a une vue, euh, hyper belle et très colorée !
C'est magnifique, c'est incroyable !
On a envie de faire quoi ?
De sortir le drone !
*Musique*
Donc comme vous avez pu le voir j'ai craqué, j'ai fait des plans
Mais le blem', c'est que ça vibrait énormément
Alors je sais pas si c'est parce qu'il y a beaucoup de vent
Ou quoi
Mais comme vous avez pu le voir sur les plans, on dirait que le sol bouge
Eh... Salut toi...
En fait dans ce village il y a plein plein de chats sur les toits
Voilà je viens de découvrir ça sur une espèce de pancarte
Donc je suis très content
Mais j'en ai vu que deux
Chez nous pour imiter un chat on fait "Miaou"
Et ici, ils font :
"Yaaaannnng, yaaaannng"
Là je suis en train de faire le chat en coréen
On a une putain de vue sur l’horizon là
Je peux vous dire que c'est très très beau
J'adore les paysages en fait dans les montagnes comme ça
Il y a beaucoup plus de relief, ça ressort bien
Voilà, c’était "National Geographic" à bientôt
Bon, vous connaissez sûrement Miro
Le meilleur Winston du monde sur Overwatch
Qui a gagné le championnat du monde d'Overwatch avec sa team la Corée du Sud
Et bah le mec pèse tellement
Qu'ils lui ont fait une allée
Voilà
Et c'était une longue introduction finalement, pour une blague un peu nulle...
Ok les amis je suis au Jagalchi Market
Et c'est le plus grand marché de poisson de Corée du Sud !
IL Y EN A PARTOUT !
*Poisson*
Les amis j'me trouve devant l'un des nombreux stands de poissons
Et il y a, les "Penis-fishs"
On dirait totalement des pénis
C'est incroyable !
Voilà je suis content parce que je suis venu ici pas dans le but de manger du bon poisson très très bon
Juste pour voir des poissons en forme de bites
Et ce stand est aussi un restaurant, donc il y a moyen qu'on aille, y manger
OK chuis rentré dans le restaurant et chuis content j'avais pas vu mais c'est les restaurants où tu manges un petit peu en mode traditionnel quoi...
en tailleur sous la table comme devant Stranger Things sur ta table basse
Il a pas aimé ma blague il me regarde mal
il a pas du tout aimé ma blague
y'a de la langouste, du crabe, du poisson-penis
Alors ce qui est ouf en Corée
C'est que avant de t'amener ce que tu as commandé à manger, ils t’amènent plein de PuneShang
Et en fait à Séoul t'en as 3, 4 mais à Busan, je suis arrivé à Busan dès que je mange au restaurant ils en amènent 8 ou 9
y'a tout ça mon gars !
Et ça j'ai pas commandé hein ! C'est offert avec!
T'as du kimshi, t'as du chou, t'as des lamamé juste là !
T'as du Pepsi. Nan ça j'ai commandé
Voici donc les "poissons-pénis"
on dirait qu'il arrive découpé prêt à être mangé
C'est tellement gluant qu'j'arrive pas à les choper avec les baguettes
'coute ça sent pas mauvais
*Dégout*
Bah franchement, j'ai jamais goûté un zizi et j’espère que ça a pas ce goût là du tout  *fier de sa blague*
Bon grosse blague y'a une coréenne âgée qui vient de passer en me regardant bizarrement
J'comprends pas trop. En fait pour venir ici tu retires tes chaussures à l'entrée
Et tu te mets en chaussettes
Et moi y'avait plusieurs paires de claquettes à l'entrée
donc je me suis mis bien!
J'ai pris une paire de claquettes ! Le problème c'est qu'ça , ça appartient aux employés du restaurant
Du coup y'a un keum qui marche en chaussettes à cause de moi
Je lui ai pris sa putain de paire de claquettes
Faut que j'm'excuse
Va falloir payer l’addition va être salée! Comme le poisson grillé
Et on va rendre ses claquettes
Après franchement si je puis me permettre
J'pense que y'a anguille sous roche
Anguiiille
Ok pour m'rattraper j'vous met une p'tite séquence cool .. Résumé du marché
*musique traditionnelle*
Comme vous venez de le voir sur cette dernière image on dirait vraiment des zizis quoi
En fait quand tu le prends et que tu le presses
y'a de l'eau qui sort de lui , 'fin c'est un délire
Ils sont 10 fois plus gros sans déconner
Là c'est le poisson adulte quoi
Bon comme en témoigne cette porte, je suis à la fin du marché
C'était ENORME !
Et ce qui est étonnant c'est y'a pleins de poissons partout et de fruits de mer
mais ça sent pas du tout mauvais
ça sent même méga bon c'est ouf.
C'qu'on va faire maintenant c'est aller se détendre dans une source chaude
Ça va être absolument génial, et reposant j'ai hâte de vous montrer ça.
Je vais mettre mon p'tit corps de lâche à nu comme ça en retirant mes habits
Et je vais m'introduire dans un bassin très très chaud
ça y est les amis je suis au spa, dans quelques secondes je vais aller dehors
je vais cailler ma race tant que je serai pas dans l'eau !
En plus j'vais devoir de me baigner avec un bras hors de l'eau parce que j'ai mon tatouage
Je crois que t'as pas la droit de te baigner pendant une deux ou trois semaines quand tu viens de te faire tatouer...
Le froid nous attend dehors !
Ok les amis j'viens de sortir, nique sa mère comment il fait froid
Je caille, je sais pas où faut aller, j'en sais rien je suis juste en train de mourir gratuitement
Ah là y'a un truc, c'est quoi ça? On dirait même pas qu'y a de l'eau mec , y'a pas d'eau, c'est pas là!
Bordel, j'vais mourir avant d'atteindre l'eau mec !
Oh putain ! C'est pas là! J'fais demi tour mec !
Bon énorme "Fail", j'crois qu'les trucs où y'a de l'eau, bah là y'a pas d'eau du coup j'vais m'barrer!
Bon les amis, j'suis dans l'ascenseur, en fait le cinquième c'est juste un "open air" comme c'est marqué là mais où y'a rien, c'est juste un espace "open"
Avec de l'air .. y'a pas d'eau !
Et au quatrième étage, c'est le spa des hommes, là où on va aller, le 'blem c'est qui faut s'mettre complétement à poil donc j'vais pas du tout pouvoir filmer
Dès maintenant, dès que ça s'ouvre j'peut plus filmer , attention j'peux plus filmer adieu !
C'était une expérience extraordinaire
Déjà moi j'aime très peu me mettre tout nu devant des gens
C'qui est à priori normal
Là j'suis à poil au moment où j'vous parle, j'suis entrain de me rhabiller
En gros, y'a pleins de douches, des sources chaudes à différentes températures
C'est la première fois d'ma vie que j'vois autant de mecs à poils, les asiat' ne se rasent pas
*rire très mature*
J'me suis douché et y'avait 3 coréens, au calme qu'étaient comme ça sur le rebord de la source chaude
Et qui m'observaient,c'était très perturbant !
Mais j'me sens bien, ça m'a bien relaxé, ça a bien marché !
Et en fait les Coréens, ils viennent ici en fin de journée, ça coûte 12 € pour 6 heures
Y'a même un p'tit espace pour dormir si tu veux te reposer faire une p'tite sieste
parce qu'ils travaillent énormément , et en gros ils viennent, il se détendent, ils s'douchent, ils s'brossent les dents
Et il retournent en soirée ou alors au boulot, je sais pas
Et là, y'a pleins de Coréens qui m'voient parler vers mon casier parce que c'est mon casier là
Et ils me dévisagent! J'appréhendais trop ce moment mais bon , j'lai fait !
Et anecdote, au Japon , y'a la même chose mais c'est des sources en plein air, là c'était pas en plein air, c'est un truc fait pour, c'est un spa
Au Japon, y'a vraiment pleins d'sources comme ça chaudes en plein air
Et t'as pas le droit d'y aller si t'es tatoué. Parce qu'au Japon, quand tu es tatoué on te considère comme un Yakuza
Vu que y'a que les Yakuzas qu'on des tatouages là-bas!
J'suis allé dans le bain à 43 à un moment, j'ai voulu faire le "kéké"
Et ça m'a donné immédiatement chaud donc j'suis allé dans la piscine à 22 degrés
Exprès pour te refroidir
Sauf que 22 degrés après 43, t'as l'impression qu'c'est -30 degrés
J'ai mis les pieds ça leur a fait du bien !
J'espère que ce petit trois-quatrième jour en Corée vous a plu
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo comme d'habitude et j'vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine!
Au revoir , à bientôt ! *Bip Bip*
*musique d'outro*